Riddled with continuity errors and plot holes
and plagued by the notorious CGI removal of
a super-stache, the theatrical release of
Justice League was a huge disappointment for
many fans;
however, the Snyder Cut has finally been able
to fix a long list of mistakes, errors and
unanswered questions from the Joss Whedon
version of the movie.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan, and
in this video I'm explaining the top 17 DC
plot holes and problems fixed in Zack Snyder's
Justice League.
Of course, spoilers ahead so take care.
The theatrical release of Justice League was
vague and short on details about the Mother
Boxes and why they had only awoken after Superman's
death.
Even worse, the Whedon reshoots ended up contradicting
the timeline established in Batman V Superman
for the experiment that Silas Stone performed
on Victor because in the theatrical release
Silas didn't get hold of a Mother Box until
just after Superman's death.
"It was shelved till the night Superman died.
Then she lit up like Christmas.
They brought it to S.T.A.R.
Labs where my father recognized it as a perpetual
energy matrix."
This is inconsistent with BvS where Wonder
Woman saw footage of Victor's transformation
into Cyborg with the Mother Box before the
battle with Doomsday and subsequent death
of Superman.
The Snyder Cut instead remains faithful to
the original timeline and establishes that
well before Superman died, Silas Stone found
a way to harness the energy from the Mother
Box.
"Victor's father activated a Mother Box more
than a year ago when Superman was still alive.
Didn't call out to Steppenwolf.
None of the boxes did.
Not until..."
"Not until Superman died."
"It's like they were afraid of him?"
That line also explains that it was very specifically
Superman's death and the powerful, anguished
death cries of the Kryptonian
which we see in the opening scene of the Snyder
Cut that awaken the Mother Boxes to send a
message out to Apokalips, as Diana later explains
to Bruce:
"Something woke the box my people guard.
It called out to the dark place...
to one of Darkseid's conquerors."
Something introduced during Whedon's reshoots
on Justice League was the idea that Parademons
can sniff out fear.
Batman used a criminal's fear as bait to catch
a Parademon at the beginning of the movie,
and Steppenwolf mentions it when he's threatening
the hostages from STAR Labs.
"The stench of your fear is making my soldiers
hungry."
This creates a plot hole though because at
that moment the Justice League are hiding
just outside the room where the hostages are
being held and Flash reveals that he's petrified.
"I'm afraid of bugs and, uh, guns and obnoxiously
tall people."
Which begs the question, why didn't the Parademons
sense Barry Allen's fear and discover him?
On top of that inconsistency, this fear concept
is used in the final battle against Steppenwolf,
when he becomes suddenly afraid of the Justice
League after Superman and Wonder Woman destroy
his axe.
"No!
This cannot be."
"You recognize that smell?"
"Fear."
"Get off me!"
This ends up being a rather disappointing
way for the movie's big bad to go out,
especially in comparison to the final battle
in the Snyder Cut which is much more epic
with Superman first slicing off one of the
villain's horns
and then the team killing him and sending
his head through the boom tube to land at
Darkseid's feet.
Thankfully the whole Parademon fear subplot
and resultant plot hole has been completely
removed from the Snyder Cut,
and instead the only significant mention of
fear is this badass moment after Steppenwolf
arrives in the Amazonian stronghold:
"I will bathe in your fear."
"Daughters of Themyscira, show him your fear!"
"We have no fear!"
A cryptic moment from Bruce Wayne's Knightmare
that's never been fully explained is when
Future Flash arrives to give Batman a message:
"It's Lois Lane!
She's the key!"
In the Whedon reshoots, it seemed this was
partially explained when Batman arranged with
Alfred to bring in Lois Lane as a back-up
in case Superman's resurrection went wrong:
"Diana was right about the risk.
If the plan goes south, we're gonna bring
in the big guns."
Although in both versions of Justice League,
it's Lois who arrives just in time to calm
Superman down, in the Snyder Cut, this has
nothing to do with Batman, Lois is simply
making her final visit to Superman's memorial
by herself.
In fact, Snyder has said that the Flash's
warning from the future about Lois Lane is
referring to something much bigger and several
scenes in the Snyder Cut elaborate on what
he's hinting at:
"Barry Allen was right here and he said to
me,
'Lois Lane is the key.'
"She is...
to Superman."
"I think it's something more.
Something darker."
We know from Cyborg's premonition that Lois
will die and the epilogue scene between Batman
and Joker also reveals that Batman was somehow
at fault for her death, which led Superman
to go to the dark side.
"You, need me to help you undo this world
you created by letting her die."
The Snyder Cut also includes an interesting
additional scene with Lois where we see she
has a pregnancy test in her bedside drawer,
which she then picks up and goes to use in
the bathroom.
Following on with the baby theme, there's
a notable difference in the Snyder Cut in
the final scene at the Clark family homestead
where Lois is carrying a baby basket into
the house rather than the removal box seen
in the Whedon cut.
Snyder in fact has said that Lois's pregnancy
is something the studio had asked to be removed
before he stopped work on the movie in 2017.
A debatable plot hole that some fans have
noticed in the Whedon cut of the Gotham Harbour
tunnels scene
is that it shouldn't be possible for the Flash
to move people around safely at super-speed
when they aren't wearing a protective suit
like him.
The Snyder Cut resolves this issue specifically
by not having Flash move anyone around in
the tunnels
and instead he simply zips back and forth
showing people where to go and later on he
uses his super-speed to rapidly move a stack
of rubble that's about to fall onto the hostages
when they get out of the tunnels.
The dangers of the Speed Force are also clearly
shown in the Snyder Cut scene where Barry
Allen's shoes disintegrate as he turns in
them at super-speed when he goes to rescue
Iris West.
It goes without saying that Snyder's Justice
League restores Henry Cavill's stacheless
Superman scenes,
doing away with the dreadful opening sequence
from the Whedon cut where the Avengers director
seemed so desperate to be acknowledged for
his hard work on the film that he included
this sign.
But more importantly fans finally got to see
Superman in his iconic black suit from the
Death of Superman comic book storyline, which
had been teased before the theatrical release
but was never delivered.
The Snyder Cut also connects to and elaborates
properly on the Knightmare scene from Batman
V Superman, part of a much larger storyline
and something which was essentially ignored
in the theatrical cut of Justice League,
leaving fans wondering what the point of it
had been.
The Snyder Cut on the other hand begins to
answer some of our questions about that enigmatic
dream from BvS.
The first revelation comes in the premonition
of the future that Cyborg sees just before
Superman is resurrected in the Kryptonian
ship.
In that vision, we see a dark future of a
dead Wonder Woman with Darkseid arriving to
conquer Themyscira;
the death of Aquaman at the hands of the Dark
God;
and a grieving Superman holding the charred
remains of Lois Lane as he's about to be brainwashed
and taken over by Darkseid.
The Snyder Cut's epilogue also continues Bruce
Wayne's dreams of a post-apocalyptic future
as we see the Dark Knight forced to work with
his enemies Deathstroke and the Joker.
This scene is also interesting because for
many fans it's a marked improvement on Jared
Leto's Joker that we saw in Suicide Squad.
The tattoos on his head which were generally
disliked have gone or are at least covered
up,
and this scene now confirms his involvement
in the death of Robin, which was alluded to
in Batman V Superman via the graffitied costume
in the Batcave.
"Why you sent the Boy Wonder to do a man's
job?"
This scene, which Snyder added in reshoots
specifically for this Cut, is also a nod to
his idea for a Batman and Joker film which
would explore the death of Robin, something
the director has admitted is unlikely to happen
now.
A character who got completely short-changed
in the theatrical version of Justice League
was Cyborg.
It seems he was the main character who suffered
from the crazy studio mandate that the movie
had to be a maximum of two hours long,
which seems especially ridiculous given that
in the Whedon cut screen time was given over
to adding a random Russian family in order
to supposedly make the conflict more relatable
to ordinary people.
In the theatrical version,
Cyborg wasn't an especially interesting character
and his backstory was extremely underdeveloped
with just a few slight references to the accident
in which he lost his mother and the reason
that his father experimented on him.
In fact, Ray Fisher has even said that almost
every single scene of him in the theatrical
cut was from the Whedon reshoots.
The Snyder Cut thankfully revolutionises our
view of Cyborg, putting him as Zack Snyder
himself has said, at the heart of the story.
We get to see Victor Stone's kindness, his
troubled relationship with his father,
him learning to use his powers and becoming
a crucial part of the team from fixing Batman's
Flying Fox to confronting his own insecurities
in order to defeat the Mother Boxes.
On top of that, watching his own father sacrifice
himself in order to place a tracker on the
third Mother Box is a particularly emotional
moment and adds another layer to the character,
in sharp contrast to the Whedon version where
Silas Stone is still alive at the end of the
movie.
Another character who gets more development
in the Snyder Cut is Barry Allen, with this
version setting up the Flash's upcoming movie
much better.
Barry saved the world when he reversed time
allowing Cyborg and Superman to separate the
boxes before they formed the Unity.
We also saw him reverse time briefly during
the Superman resurrection scene when he didn't
quite reach the Mother Box in time to charge
it initially.
This ability in the Snyder Cut together with
the first mention of the multiverse in the
DCEU movies so far, and the Joker discussing
alternate timelines with Batman in the epilogue,
set the stage for the Flashpoint movie in
a more satisfying way than the theatrical
version did.
And although Barry is still the comic relief
among the group in both versions of the film,
gone are some of the worst parts of Whedon's
reshoots such as Barry drawing on a prison
visitor's face, the tedious brunch jokes and,
of course, the moment where he falls on top
of Wonder Woman,
a tiresome joke that Whedon obviously finds
so hilarious that he recycled it from Avengers:
Age of Ultron.
We also lost several other cringe-worthy Whedon
additions such as Martha telling Lois Lane
that Clark said she was "the thirstiest girl
he ever met"
and Aquaman calling Wonder Woman 'gorgeous'
while under the influence of the Lasso of
Truth.
And there's an interesting technical fix to
the scene where the Justice League break into
STAR Labs.
In the theatrical release, the date of birth
of Barry's fake military profile is November
2010, which at the time of the film's release,
2017, would have made the character only 7
years old.
In the Snyder Cut, the date has been fixed
so that the birth year is now 1997.
Also much improved and fixed in Snyder's Justice
League are the villains.
Steppenwolf's design has been vastly upgraded
together with his backstory and motivation
for collecting the Mother Boxes.
It was a really intriguing added detail for
his armour to change with his mood and even
retract entirely when he prostrates himself
in front of Darkseid.
Steppenwolf is still a big CGI villain in
both versions, but his character is much better
developed in the Snyder Cut,
which makes the final battle with him and
the way the Justice League defeat him much
more satisfying than in the theatrical version.
But on top of that, the Snyder Cut also properly
reveals the real big bad of the movie and
of the Snyderverse as a whole, Darkseid, who
was referred to but never properly explained
in the Whedon cut.
In the Snyder Cut,
Darkseid also replaced Steppenwolf during
the extended and much more satisfying flashback
to the invasion of Earth when the Amazons,
Atlanteans, Gods, Green Lanterns and men successfully
resisted and repelled the villain and his
minions.
Something that puzzled many fans at the end
of the theatrical release is how Lex Luthor
managed to escape from Arkham Asylum.
The Snyder Cut doesn't fully explain this
but does give a hint in the much longer epilogue
scene with Luthor and Deathstroke on the boat.
"I heard you were a few clowns short of a
circus."
"I was, thank you, until the good doctors
at Arkham helped me find some much needed
clarity."
This clown reference may hint that the Joker
was involved in Luthor's prison break
and the mention of doctors here might also
suggest that Luthor bribed some of the staff
at the facility to send over a bald lookalike
into his cell while he escaped.
Another unanswered question from the theatrical
cut some fans have wondered about is how Aquaman
knew about the Atlantean Mother Box.
The Snyder Cut's restoration of a deleted
scene between Arthur and Vulko helps clear
this up:
"The snatchers have come from the dark place.
They're looking for it.
The Mother Box our people guard is not safe.
Go to the stronghold of Atlantis."
Likewise for Wonder Woman, the inclusion of
a deleted scene where Diana visits the Shrine
of the Amazons explains how she learned about
Darkseid's previous invasion of Earth.
The Snyder Cut isn't entirely faultless though
and there are a few inconsistencies that this
version of the film seems to have introduced
in particular how it relates to the Aquaman
movie.
For example, Mera has a very strange British
accent which is completely at odds with the
American accent she had in the Whedon cut
and the Aquaman film.
"Where the legends say Atlan's trident was
forged."
"He's as shortsighted as he is cruel."
And then there's the way Aquaman tosses his
shirts into the ocean and smashes whiskey
bottles by the shore but complains about rubbish
being thrown into the sea in his own movie.
Now, did you spot other problems that the
Snyder Cut fixes or any new plot holes in
this version of the movie?
Comment below and if you enjoyed this video
do leave a thumbs-up.
Tap here to check out some more videos you
might like including the deleted alternate
ending and cut scenes for The Boys Season
2.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!